how many gpus entire box six
[Laughter]
oh man and I'll tell you why it's sex
yeah uh so AMD epic processors have 128
Lanes of pcie
um I want to leave enough lanes for
some uh drives and I want to leave
enough lanes for some networking how do
you do cooling for something like this
Ah that's one of the big challenges not
only do I want the cooling to be good I
want it to be quiet I want the Tiny Box
to be able to sit comfortably in your
room this is really going towards the
girlfriend thing because you want to run
an llm I'll give I'll give them more I
mean I can talk about how it relates to
company number one
come AI yeah
well but yes quiet oh quiet because you
may be a potential one around in a car
no no quiet because you want to put this
thing in your house and you want and you
want to coexist with you if it's
screaming at 60 DB you don't want that
in your house you'll kick it out 60 DB
yeah yeah I'm only like 40 45. so how do
you make the cooling uh quiet that's an
interesting problem in itself
um a key trick is to actually make it
big ironically it's called the Tiny Box
yeah but if I can make it big a lot of
that noise is generated because of high
pressure air if you look at like a 1u
server a 1u server has to be super high
pressure fans they're like super deep
and they they're like Janus versus if
you have something that's big well I can
use a big and you know you know they
call them Big Ass Fans those ones that
are like huge on the ceiling and they're
completely silent so tiny box
will be big
it is the uh I do not want it to be
large according to UPS I want it to be
shippable as a normal package but that's
my constraint there
interesting well the the fans stuff that
can't it be assembled on location no no
no I should be well you're you're look I
want to give you a great out of the box
experience I want you to lift this thing
out I want it to be like like the Mac
you know
Tiny Box the Apple experience yeah
I love it okay